to expand our testing capacity and to
improve our understanding this virus
there are two developments that I wanted
to share with you today the first is
around swab test these are the sweats
these are the tests that tell you if you
currently have corona virus as I
announced on Monday
anybody over five who has symptoms is
now eligible for a test and getting a
test is important but getting a quick
result is important too we're working
hard on innovative developments and I
wanted to bring you up to speed with
this now it's really important to be
clear about this
working with innovative science always
has its risks like all R&D lots of
projects don't come off and just like
for instance vaccines where we don't
know if we'll ever get one but I'm
prepared to back innovative developments
even if they might never happen I think
it's worth it and I think it's worth it
especially in these circumstances to
back things before you know for sure if
they're going to work and I make no
apologies for that we're working with
many top names to help us deliver
testing with a rapid turnaround names
like Oxford nanopore and chronometer and
DNA nudge for example one innovative
company opted to gene has produced an
early test which is by being trialed
from today and it is interesting to us
because it is so fast it doesn't need to
be sent to a lab to be processed and so
you get the result on the spot typically
within around 20 minutes it's already
proven effective in early trials and we
want to find out if it will be effective
on a larger scale and we want to support
companies like op - gene and others to
develop these sorts of innovative
projects we'll monitor its effectiveness
very closely and if it works we'll roll
it out as soon as we can now this is
just one of a number of innovative
testing technologies that we're pushing
forward as fast as the science allows I
will need leave no stone unturned and I
want to thank everybody involved for
their dedication the second development
I wanted to share today is around
antibody tests these tell you if you
have
at the virus and have developed
antibodies in response that might help
you to fight the virus in future covert
19 is a new virus and we're learning
more about it every single day I want to
be frank with you about what we don't
know as well as what we do know we're
not yet in a position to say that those
who test positive in these antibody
tests are immune from coronavirus but as
our understanding of the disease
improves the insight these antibody
tests provide will be crucial they can
help us to understand how our bodies
react to coronavirus and how its spread
across the country we're backing efforts
to develop our own homegrown antibody
tests through our UK rapid test
consortium and that work is showing some
early promise and as you know we've been
looking at a whole series of commercial
antibody tests now many of these early
tests were not reliable enough for
clinical use but we have made some
available at the small scale and we now
have the results of our antibodies
surveillance study this has told us that
around 17% of people in London and
around 5% or higher in the rest of the
country have tested positive for
coronavirus antibodies this was based on
a sample but for the public at large to
know whether or not they've had
coronavirus we need antibody tests at
larger scale to lab based products
produced by Ross Diagnostics and Abbott
Labs have been given a positive
evaluation by Phe and approved by the
MHRA and three further tests are being
assessed right now and I can announce
today that we have signed contracts to
supply in the coming months over 10
million tests from Ross and Abbott from
next week we'll begin rolling these out
in a phased way at first to health and
care staff patients and residents the UK
government has arranged supplies of
these tests on behalf of the devolved
administration's and each devolved
nation is deciding how to use its test
allocation and how testing will be
prioritized and managed locally this is
an important milestone and it represents
further progress in our national testing
program it's not just about the clinical
advances that these tests can bring
although obviously that's important it's
that knowing that you have these
antibodies will help us to understand
more in the future if you are at lower
risk of catching coronavirus of dying
from corona virus and of transmitting
corona virus we're developing this
critical science to know the impact of a
positive antibody test and to develop
the systems of certification to ensure
people who have positive antibodies can
be given assurance about what they can
safely do history has shown that
understanding an enemy is fundamental to
defeating it and in this latest fight
our ingenuity and our brilliant
scientists and our scientific curiosity
are what will keep us one step ahead of
this virus